parlez nous sommes avec gérard vespière
un chercheur associé à la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient bonjour et
merci d'être avec nous sur cette attaque
est ce que vous retenez de ce propos
écoutez je pense qu'on a affaire à un
discours allez je vais vous dire
exactement ce que je pense puisque vous
demandez exactement ce que je pense
langue de bois ça on a eu beaucoup de
mal à à suivre le fil de cette
intervention là alors c'était peut-être
aussi pour des questions techniques
liées à une traduction un peu compliqué
donc parce que la russie est aussi un
carrefour difficilement a donc avec une
intervention militaire quand même très
sérieuse en en syrie où donc 380 mille
morts des millions de déplacés
donc intervenir au nom des droits de
l'homme c'est difficile politiquement a
donc aussi des manifestations à
l'intérieur de la russie sur les
questions d'expression de liberté
d'expression donc voilà c'est un
exercice qui n'est pas facile devant un
auditoire international à la russie donc
a effectivement faire à man à doit
montrer un certain nombre d'événements
d'éléments positifs
elle essaie d'être là le porte parole
d'un certain nombre de pays et d'être en
pointe vis-à-vis d'un d'un certain
nombre de ces pays là il a été fait
référence aux aux pays baltes ou lit à
des minorités russes
il était référence à l'ukraine où il y a
aussi des minorités russophones a donc
c'est un exercice compliqué à à vivre
pour la russie qui est au milieu de deux
situations différentes
ce qu'on peut retenir aussi ce sont ces
propos de sergueï lavrov en substance il
invita à mener un dialogue je le cite
pas exactement c'est beau mais ce qu'on
retient c'est que il invite à mener un
dialogue dépolitiser pour ne pas imposer
des valeurs qui reflète la morale
d'autres pays la russie propose un
dialogue pluraliste sur la question des
droits de l'homme comment un ministre
peut-il avoir un appel à un discours
dépolitiser
spa c'est voilà c'est on touche quand
même là la limite de la rhétorique à
l'évidence un homme politique a exprimé
des positions politiques alors à l'ordre
du jour aussi de cette deuxième session
de cette deuxième journée de la session
annuelle du conseil des droits de
l'homme de l'onu à l'ordre du jour
cette conférence sur le désarmement il
en a été question il y à quelques
dizaines de minutes et sergueï lavrov a
pointé du doigt la politique menée par
les états unis en la matière alors
effectivement il y a deux types de
d'accord nucléaire a actuellement un
accord nucléaire sûre donc les forces
intermédiaire aliyev et puis à un accord
sur les armes stratégiques
donc dans l'accord sur les armes
intermédiaires à les etats-unis en sont
sortis a donc il y avait des raisons
pour cela il fait plusieurs années que
les états unis ont exprimé leur
inquiétude vis-à-vis d'essai d'un
missile très précis à nouveau mené par
des essais donc mené par la russie
le 3ème 729 il vous bon et donc il
considéré depuis des années que ce
missile était en dehors de l'accord bon
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont exprimé leur
désir d'en sortir
concernant à la les accords sur les
arsenaux nucléaires stratégiques à la
l'accord est toujours en place fait la
dernière star star voilà qui est
normalement bon à fin 2021 doit être
renouvelé là nous sommes dans une
situation très intéressante d'un point
de vue négociations la russie a mis en
avant de nouveaux types d'armements donc
département désarmement hypersonique
donc de très grandes vitesses d'arriver
sur les sites d'impact et aussi de très
grande agilité avant la cites donc là il
ya une opportunité pour la russie de
dire j'ai une avance technologique
j'ai une avance de savoir faire
militaire comment puis-je à tirer
avantage de cela et je pense que c'est
un élément important des négociations à
venir
et c'est dans ce cadre aussi que la
russie propose l'élaboration d'une
convention internationale pour la lutte
contre le terrorisme chimique et
biologique
non ça c'est un autre volet donc est bon
on peut effectivement regarder ce qui se
passe à nouveau en syrie donc là on à
l'utilisation d'armes chimiques pas ces
derniers temps mais enfin historiquement
depuis 8 10 ans était le cas donc
effectivement il ya besoin de faire une
avancée sur ce genre de procédé
d'intervention en particulier sur des
populations civiles sur cette question
du désarmement tout à l'heure à st gall
a bravé a mis en avant ce qu'il juge
être là la seule proposition 1 positive
à savoir la proposition russo chinoise
contre le déploiement des forces dans
l'espace notre but je le cite éviter
toute militarisation de l'espace sur ce
point là ça tient toujours pas écouté je
pense que l'espace est déjà militarisé
l'espace et militarisé de façon passive
c'est-à-dire qu'il a été utilisé pour
observer à pour détecter a donc quel que
soit le pays a les chinois les russes
les etats-unis les européens la france
ont des satellites radar on les
satellites de détection qui ont permis
de mettre en évidence que ce malheureux
vol ukrainien en partance de téhéran
avait été abattu par des missiles
quelques minutes après à la côte la
communauté internationale a su que
c'était difficile parce qu'il y avait
une observations spatiales de cette
situation merci beaucoup pour votre
analyse gérard vespière chercheur
associé à la fondation d'études pour le
à moyen-orient bien sûr merci à vous
deux